MAY THIRTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER-
PLEASE BE ADVISED AN AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BE MADE AND IS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDED A CERTAIN
BEFORE MASK AT ALL TIMES AND
COMPLY WITH GUIDANCE ON
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. ATTENDEES
MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING.
POLITICIANS OF THESE RULES MAY
SUBJECT AN INDIVIDUAL TO
REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM SENATE LARA GIPSON
YOUR LEVY YEAH MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS RAMOS YOUR RUBIO IF YOU
COULD WHAT HERE WEBER. NO CAR.
WE HAVE A QUORUM ARE WE IN AND
I. PLEASE NOTE THE FRIDAY
NUMBER NINE EIGHT SEVEN SIX
WILL HAVE A HERE ON THAT THE
CALL IN NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AGAIN. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO- TO. AGAIN
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH
TWO. AND INDIVIDUALS CAN ALSO
FIND THESE NUMBERS ON THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE. AS WELL AS ON
THEIR TV SCREENS. OF COLLEAGUES
WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA IS OUR
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
MOVERS SECONDED BY MR LEE ON MR
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY I COOLEY AYE THAT.
BENNETT I FLOOR GIPSON ALL
RIGHT GIPSON. LEAVE I MAJOR.
MAIENSCHEIN I'M- RAMOS FIVE
RAMOS AND HIGHER. RUBIO HI VIS
A WHAT FOOD WHAT HIGHER. WEBER
HI MATHIS ON. MATT HI. MOTION
SO THIS TIME I'M GONNA
SURRENDER THE GAVEL TO MISTER
MATHIS- AND RECEIVED SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO ITEM. A. B. C. OH SO BY
ASSEMBLY COLLEEN MISTER COOLEY.
WE YOU PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN I AM TO
PRESENT A BRIEF MOST- A BILL
ROLE TO THE WING OF THIS
CAPITOL BUILDING THERE WAS
PROPOSES TO ADDRESS A PASTA AND
BEGIN. ALL I WANT TO SAY THAT-
THE CONTENTS OF THE BILL WILL
PROVIDE BY LOS COUNSEL SIMPLY A
SIMPLE A VEHICLE OVER TO THE
WAY WING. IT IS A- FACT THE
WEST WERE. THAT ANY PRIDE WERE
ALL THE FIRST OR THIRD. OR THE-
HAS TO BE. BY VEHICLE THAT IS
NOW ENERGY BILL- IN TWENTY
EIGHT TO WE TO PULL VIA AND-
FOR. BUT THIS MEANS THAT WE I
WANT A VEHICLE. IN THE EVENT
THAT WORK THERE WILL BE A THIS
FALL. NEEDS ANY ARGUMENT. LATER
THE ERRORS WE SORT OF ASSESS.
WE NEED TO COME. OUR CONTRACTOR
TO COME. THIS BILL IS A VEHICLE
SUPPORT THAT AS WELL AS A TEAM.
SIX- SO I THANK YOU- AGAIN.
THIS FALL THE HUNDRED LONG
THERE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR BE
MOVING TO SWING SPACE- EFFORTS
WILL BE MADE IN THE WEST TO A
COMMON FORCE. THIS MEANS WE
NEED TO HAVE SPACE OF IN THE
CURRENT. WHICH IN LIEU OFFICE
TO ACCOMMODATE CAUCUSES FOR THE-
OF HIS HOUSE OF SERGEANTS SPACE
CLARK SPACE. TO SUPPORT ALL
GOING UP BY NEXT JANUARY WHEN
WE OUR FOR SESSIONS IN THE WEST
WING- ANSEL BILL JUST FITS IN
THE PAST OF HOW PROVIDE FOR ALL
OF THAT. REMOVES A AND- THAT. I
MY REQUEST I DO AS I SAY LAST
LOS COUNCIL FOR VEHICLE. OF.
THAT'S A MODIFICATIONS BE MADE
IN A TIMELY WAY. I THINK THIS
PRESSURE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
COOLEY WILL TO TESTS FROM
WITNESSES IN SOME OF AB SEVEN
OF SAY. SEEN YOUR PRESENT DO WE
HAVE IN THE REMOTE VIEWING.
SEEN NONE MATER DOING HAVE ANY
ON PHONE. IF YOU LIKE THIS
STATE YOUR BILL OF SUPPORT FOR
A BI SEVEN ALL SIX PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. JUST REMIND
AND WE CAN GO FIRST CONTEST THE
MONEY IS LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES
PER WITNESS. WHAT A LINE
THIRTEEN ONE THREE- I'M NOT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PLEASE PLEASE
RE QUEUE ME. THANK YOU- AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q.
FOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE OF THE
CHAMBERS MANY IN THE REMOTE
VIEWING. SEEING NONE MODERATOR
AGAIN. THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO STATE A POSITION OF
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
THAT'S ONE BEEN. ZERO HOW TO
GET FROM THAT. WE JUST A MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR. WE HAVE LINE
EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS KEN
SCOTT FROM PLASTER COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY. OPPOSE AB SEVENTY SIX
I JUST DON'T THINK THAT THE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE TIME NOR THE
MONEY TO BE DEMOLISHING AND
REBUILDING A PERFECTLY FINE
BUILDING. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE. TWENTY TWO. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. HELLO GREAT WITH
YOUR CHAIR NUMBER THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY%
FOR CAPITAL COMPETITION TO
EIGHTY SEVEN OH SIX YOU HAVE A
LETTER IN YOUR PACKET. MISTER
CHAIR I'D LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU
TO YOUR PERSONAL COMMITTEE
STAFF WHO PROVIDE COURTEOUS
OPEN AND HELPFUL ASSISTANTS TO
ASK WHY ARE WE- TO SEND A
LETTER TO TRYING TO UNDER WHAT
PROBLEM THIS BILL IS ATTEMPTING
TO REMEDY IT COULD BE A CUTS.
ISSUE WITH THE APPROPRIATION
FOR WEST WING IMPROVEMENTS IT
COULD BE THE PROBLEM OF HAVING
TO AMEND THE POS REPORT INTO
THE MO YOU WE'RE NOT QUITE SURE
BUT BOTH THOSE REMEDIES DON'T
MEMBER THE UNDER THE PROBLEM
WITH IS THE GOVERNOR STRUCTURE
OF THE CAPITOL ANNEX PROJECT AS
OUTLINED IN AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY
SIX AND THE MO YOU. WE ARE
DEEPLY OPPOSED TO THAT
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE IT HAS
CREATED A SITUATION WHERE THEY
WERE LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE BY TWO
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
ONE REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THIS IS THE
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE CREATED
MAMMAL YOU. FOCUS ARE MADE
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS THERE'S NO
NOTICE OF MEETING NO ACCESS TO
MEETINGS DISCO OF THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS IN FACT THE YOU
WOULD WITH WOULD HELP WHEN
REQUIRE IT SAME WITH THE POS
THE MEETING OF THE J. R. C. ALL
BEEN- THERE IS NO THE X. ONE TO
ADOPT THE DRAFT PO INTO. TWO
NINETEEN ALL THE WE A AS A CALL.
WHICH I WILL OUTLINE- ARE DUE
TO THE WILL REDUCE WITH PUBLIC
INVOLVED OR JUST. IS A CAPITAL
PROJECT TO DID THE P. HAVE THIS
ARE BEHIND CLOSED AND UP IS TO
IMPROVE HEARING ONLY WE ASK
THAT YOU VOTE NO THIS MAY.
THANK YOU HEARING CONCERNS.
WHEN INCLUDE RIGHTLY. THANK
THANK YOU FOR KEEP IT UNDER
MINUTES. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
SIXTY. GOOD MISS CHAIR MA'AM.
THIS IS RAY COLIN I AM WITH
PUBLIC A CAN FOR CAP. AS MR
COOLEY STAYED AB TWENTY WHICH
AND THE ANNEX- WHICH IN WERE ON
THE INTERIOR AND SAAD OF THE
STORY CAPITAL WAS AN URGENT
STAFF. WHICH ACCORDING TO THE
COST. CANNOT TAKE IF THE. IF
THIS IS TRUE. THEN THE CO
ACTION IS DISGORGE OF THE PLAN
TO PAY THAT'S- TO MOCHA PLAN.
SO M. AND- FOR THE- PLANNING
COULD COST ESTIMATING
INVESTIGATIVE IN PHYSICAL WORK
DONE TO THE PROJECT. THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE HEARINGS HAVE
BRIEFED THE MEMBERS AND THE
PUBLIC ON THE WORK- PLANNED FOR
THE AREAS ADJACENT TO THE
CHAMBERS NORTH AND SOUTH
ENTRANCES AND BOTH THE EAST AND
WEST EXTERIOR FACADES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. WE HAVE LINE.
FIFTEEN ONE FIVE. HI THERE IS
THAT JOSHUA COLEMAN CALLING FOR
ABOUT I'M AND I'M AND- BIG TO I
JUST THINK THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY TO BE SPENDING ON
THIS WE NEED TO CLEAN UP OUR
STREETS- YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE
ARE UNEMPLOYED AND BUSINESSES
ARE GOING UNDER AND THIS IS NOT
HOW WE SHOULD BE SPENDING TAX
DOLLARS SO I'M IN I'M IN BIG
OPPOSITION BUT THIS DOWN. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE LINE. NINETEEN
NINETEEN ONE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO YES THAT'S YOU BUT
OKAY I WASN'T EVEN A NUMBER- HI
MY NAME IS ADRIAN HAVE TO
PLASTER COUNTY AND I AM AGAIN
EIGHTY SEVEN I THINK AGAIN THIS
IS NOT THE TIME NOR THE PLACE
TO BE WITH SUCH. WHILE THE
AMOUNTS MONEY WHEN THE STATE
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE STATE IF
THEY AND ALL. WHEN YOU BARELY
LIKE THE PEOPLE COME IN TO THE
BUILDING GET STRESSED. THEIR
INTEREST SUPPORT THEIR- AGAINST
YOUR BUDGET. EXTENSION NOT.
THEY YOU. NEXT WE HAVE A LINE.
TWENTY TWO. I DON'T LINE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WILL
MOVE THE LINE. TWELVE THIS IS
CATHERINE CRIED PLASTER COUNTY
FORMER HISTORIC KARADZICH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M STRONGLY
DEMOLITION OF THE CAPITAL ANNEX
ANNEX AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY SIX
MAYBE SEVEN ZERO SIX BILLIONS
OF OUR TAXPAYER MONEY WOULD BE
WASTED I AGREE WITH THE
PREVIOUS CALLERS CALIFORNIA HAS
MORE SERIOUS PROBLEMS LIKE
POVERTY HOMELESSNESS OUR ROADS
DAMS PORTS ARE IN MUCH NEEDED
ATTENTION PLEASE REFOCUS AND
PRIORITIZE THIS IS NOT URGENT
BOTH NO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR WE WILL NOW TURN
BACK TO ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MR
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ON A. B. SEVEN OH SIX BY
SOMEONE NUMBER COOLEY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM SENATE
BENNETT HI FLORA GIPSON HI
GIPSON. LEVY I MAY. ME I AM HI
MATHIS AYE RAMA. RAMOS I RUBIO.
RUBIO HIGH BE APPROVED BY. THE
POOL WHILE I WEBER. WEBER HI.
PASS THANK YOU MR COOLEY MOTION
PASS IN HIS ITS WAY TO THE S.
FLOOR. SEEING NO BUSINESS I
WILL CALL THIS RULES. TO JERK.